what I'm trying to say is marriage if
you're not married you're gay
Dove miles how do you guys feel about
that okay I feel very good for gay do
you want to be married soon inshallah
inshallah miles is gay dude you don't
even believe in marriage no I do I do
now miles is going to take his girls on
his name though no I wouldn't I don't
mind if my girl didn't take my last name
what yeah we're gonna say my mom didn't
do it so why wouldn't you take it what
do you mean your mom didn't do it what's
your last name my last name is McCreery
exactly I just asked for clarification
no he gave you warnings
2.0 that's your mom I respect that
talk to you like that oh wow why are you
making a racist he said boy watching
you can you call Indians boy is that
like uh oh [ __ ] bye it is very is my his
brother yeah so it's almost like brother
[Music]
yeah it is especially Southern that's
pretty good yeah no it's not bad yeah so
I wouldn't be that upset about it but
you miles the fact that you're willing
to take your wife's name which
yeah I mean like why don't we all do
that I wouldn't mind I probably wouldn't
say why don't we all take our wives
names
tuck our [ __ ] between our legs and chop
it off on the back side I wouldn't take
her last name but I don't mind if she
didn't take mine yeah why wouldn't you
take hers
uh I just like mine and I like hers we
could just keep it separate you all know
her how you like hers and what about the
kids what about the kids you mix them up
you put them together
no not a hyphen no not a whole new last
name like I'm not gonna if it's Smith
you're gonna be like Mick Smith yeah
exactly no more Garcia para that's the
Garcia in power with the last names of
the moms put it together perfect no Mark
RC part and now I'm gonna have a
baseball player kid too so that's fire
and his name is no Marcus his dad's name
is Ramon so no more no Latinos love that
[ __ ] is that a thing I know a girl who's
whose name is an anagram of her mom's
name it's not a real name I know I love
that you said Latinos love that and
you're like I know one Latina this can
confirms it one is yes extremely
Dominican boy it's one data point but
once you have two data points that's a
pattern yeah yeah okay all right I'm
noticing something I got you analytics
yeah you know what I'm saying is it
getting more purple in here
what is going on bro I like that we got
this little colorful box that's crazy no
that's fire okay um listen I'm just
saying marriage marriage Dove you want
to go get married this is a good thing
marriage is fire longest recorded
wedding lasted 91 years 12 days the
longest recording wedding
because I was in the [ __ ] I had to be
out front had to be smiling for all the
photos and standing the whole time how
long was fired by the uh by father Ben
so wow
[Laughter]
the ground listen I thought that I
thought that nobody could give a worse
wedding speech than father Ben until my
own mother got up there at my wedding I
remember that oh dude she didn't even
have a speech you don't remember that no
she went up with a paper I was like oh
she actually wrote some things down it
was how to pronounce people's things
that's far actually no your mom could do
no wrong shut up no no no no no she
can't the uh my pops though he can do no
wrong
Andrew for those who don't know gave a
beautiful speech at his own wedding like
we were all crying
the cutest funniest part was he gets
really emotional says something to his
dad I'm not gonna say what is this
because if it's personal or not
beautiful though we're all crying and
then Andrew's dad goes
[Laughter]
because my dad's basically got like
Alzheimer's so I I think I was like uh
you know I know things are becoming as
we can only Things become hard to
remember but I just want to let you know
I remember everything in terms like what
you're getting emotional saying thinking
about it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so I see her [ __ ] rapping her wrists
in a cloth napkin I'm like what's
happening Brother give me some long ass
speech for no reason I'm looking at my
mom in tears
my brother's speech I was like hit the
[ __ ] I was sick
you were so done I couldn't believe it I
just started liking you how you got this
main memory
you tell me immediately afterwards
didn't you say something when you got up
No I gave him a hug because he had a
beautiful point and I was like that's it
let's just end this so I gave him a hug
like that's hey this is a beautiful
moment also that's enough yeah and he
told me afterward you cut me off and I
was like I saved you [ __ ] what
are you talking about yeah yeah you the
light dog you did cut them off hey
that's enough
yeah you're [ __ ] rambling yeah
figuring out dog you do feel that yes I
gotta tell you all about the best
wallets in the business damn right okay
you know what's happening you're walking
down the street some dudes bumping into
you and he's stealing all your
information you don't even realize it
they don't gotta steal your wallet
distill your information you know you
pay for a coffee you just tap your phone
on the thing someone could tap your
thigh or your back pocket while you're
walking down the street steal all your
[ __ ] not if you got an extra extra got
the RFID protection it protects you
against Boop steal all your information
okay the best wallet in the business
look how cool they got this nice little
leather one you can even put that little
what is that thing called miles an air
or something
air tag you can even air tag it so you
never have to lose it I'm telling you
this is the best in the business it's
trackable worldwide this is the one
while you will not lose okay you're not
gonna lose the wallet and nobody's gonna
take what's in it from you and it's a
no-brainer because you're getting up to
20 off site wide when you use the code
flagrant exeter.com so check out the
wallets at extra
ekster.com and get up to 20 off site
wide with the code flagrant now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
you know what's weird about weddings is
that people continue to make the
mistakes that they hate
yeah like the speeches go on forever and
when you're at someone else's wedding
you're like God damn he speaks as long
as a [ __ ] and then you go and
have your own wedding and the speech is
a long as a [ __ ] because they're
not alone to you yeah no they're long
they're long they're long but it was for
them but I was embarrassed for my whole
family what I wanted my mom my dad my
aunt my uncle who helped raise me y'all
come up two y'all make speeches all four
of them all of a sudden I know them to
have stage fright all of a sudden they
all want to speak I bring all my
siblings up two of them have stage
fright my brother's gonna make a speech
that's it all of a sudden they all want
to give speeches [ __ ] what
like his was long but his was a banger
so it was good so if everybody thinks oh
mine this is one of the greatest
speakers in the world right now my my
mom wasn't even that long no you're so
short it was I think it was like 60
seconds yeah I didn't say your mom I'm
just saying everybody who gives a speech
they think their speech is a banger no
they got it they don't know that they're
going they gotta know dude no they don't
know even if even if we gotta tell them
tell me in private the podium is first
second third ombre mentioned can be at
the rehearsal or some [ __ ] you know what
I mean Camille gave a great speech to
Andrew's wedding short get in get out
both of you guys gave great short
speeches at the wedding perfect and I
knew it too and I was like oh [ __ ] they
gonna go up they gonna knock this [ __ ]
out and then
because they don't know no better you
know yeah and I think maybe you put so
much pressure on yourself because it's
like all right I gotta knock it out I
gotta say everything yes that's the
[ __ ] hard part I was cutting fat bro
I was rehearsing I was like that's too
long cut it out get to the [ __ ] meat
punching it up yeah cut the fat calling
you ask her you're like yo can you yeah
can we do something on this screen
okay okay what did you hate about your
wedding
the speeches really yeah mostly one yeah
my brothers because I was like Phil I'm
so excited for you to talk I was the
best man at my brother's wedding and
then he was the best man his brother's
ready and I was like oh it's full circle
my brother's the best man on my wedding
yeah and I'm so excited for you to speak
and he goes well anyway Andrew Schultz
is here
let's hear what he has to say and I go I
hear what he has to say every [ __ ]
day I don't need to hear what he has to
say I'm here to see what you have to say
and he was like it was so funny let's
throw it up to Andrew I was like I was
not asked to speak I know you did it and
you didn't even want to I didn't want
you to do no one wanted you yeah but my
brother Phil's like yeah let's have him
speak he actually did a good job it was
fun no I didn't do a good job I I got I
went blue real quick
it did go Blue real quick that's what
you need though that sucks jokes but uh
but yeah that was that was fun yeah that
was fun I'm trying to think yeah you
think back about that day and it's the
best day but you're like how do you
change it also I have no confidence that
akash's Mike is picking up anything
right now it is it is unbelievable it's
like pointing the opposite direction
yeah yeah yeah it is I wonder if you
even zip up the jacket or something like
that you might get kind of hot I'm fine
getting hot as long as it sounds good
yeah I just want you guys know this is
just fine yeah I know
because cassette was looking at his
jacket like giving him that like oh
you're not gonna be allowed in here with
that jacket yeah and Akash was like come
on don't come on
well the zipper ain't working so give me
a second it's okay oh gosh I'm vomited
at Mark's wedding in front of his family
wait really yeah why I drank too much I
mean what do you think doggy who's
nervous about the speeches yeah but
why'd you vomit in front of the family
well I went outside thinking oh it's
dark out here no one's gonna be around
here I'm drunk yeah and then I look up
and the whole family's just around the
corner [ __ ] red I do kind of wish I
didn't do that [ __ ] during covet I'll be
honest do you wish that your friends
weren't doing so much coke at your
wedding no I wish more coke less covid
and more money wait why why why why why
because all those things make it better
isn't the other isn't the thing about
weddings like uh or maybe it's just
because we've been doing okay but like
when you're planning financially for
your wedding yeah you're always
conservative you know how the [ __ ] am I
going to pay for this yeah and as you
know hopefully life goes well you make
more money and you're like man why did I
just Splurge
I spent I have all the money I had no
mail to pay for it really yeah I paid
for it myself really my aunt paid for
the DJ you know shout out to your aunt
yeah that was nice yeah yeah we got one
of those paid for anything yeah at least
his family like the wife's family
supposed to pay for stuff and they're
like yeah we're gonna yo son she was
like we'll help cook that was their
first thought they go we'll help cook
and I was like you're not cooking yeah
my parents kept asking me when I was
gonna get married and I was like you not
contributing to nothing [ __ ] you talking
about
so that's why I'm like I'm gonna do a
five-year wedding anniversary that then
is going to be proportional to my
lifestyle and I'm like yeah let's go to
a destination and then just redo the
wedding yeah but like we'll renew our
vows yes and then we'll do a party after
yeah and it's just gonna be like more
fun I like that can Andrew speak at that
one too yes I'm definitely gonna speak
we're going to have a speech prepared
yeah we're doing the same seat he'll go
Blue at the end now can I can I the only
part of your wedding that I almost booed
there was one part that I almost
literally screwed no no I almost food is
when we started singing Happy Birthday
my brain almost exploded yeah I know I
get because you don't have any more of
these you got left not too many your
grandma could give a [ __ ] she's an
ornery an ornery broad no but I don't
think she was like I'm not getting any
attention or something she's she's
ornery no but like I can get this energy
from her at all that she needs attention
or needed to be acknowledged
yeah yeah well the other issue is that
it was like oh yeah I want my sister to
have a happy birthday it's her birthday
we're getting married I want to wish her
happy birthday like she want to do that
for her sister and then my feet of your
wife and then my mom swoops in and she's
like we got the most unique wife in
history
never in history has a woman get married
and wanted something for someone else
yeah I wanted not even us yeah
and is like oh well if you're gonna do
it for her be rude to sing for her and
not my mom oh come on Mom and then I
should have come on I wish at the time I
wasn't a [ __ ] kid so I could be like
no we're not doing that no one's saying
we're singing from me if anything like
enough with this singing for other
people so it is amazing how the parents
make it about themselves yeah it is so
unbel I have my mom get absolutely
shit-faced through the the week after
when we got back
and she's like she's like she's like you
didn't spend nearly enough time with me
I go what Jesus you posted the Wii
dancing video with us but you barely
talk to me it's your wedding I'm like
dude woman
take your fat [ __ ] tits and mind your
goddamn business about my wedding can I
just have an enjoyable [ __ ] one night
I know please okay
if it makes me my dad [ __ ] called me
he's like when are you getting married
that looks much better yeah okay that
worked out perfectly oh
how did you make it about you yeah it's
remarkable you got to cut that [ __ ] off
early what is that I was I'm not
normally rude to my parents but any
wedding stuff I was like we're gonna
have the wedding we can afford to have
and we want to have yeah that's it yeah
that's what's happening yeah and then
they get the idea pretty quickly that
like they're not this is not their thing
they didn't she didn't put any pressure
leading up to it
um my mind did yeah yeah you got to cut
that off no immediately yeah oh yeah
that was smart take notes would you do
that would you do a valve renewal party
thing I think I think yeah we talked
about it I think it yeah it'd be really
cool it just seems awesome it seems
great yeah just a big party yeah yeah if
you got invited to the first one that
ticket is still valid and then you bring
in some new people that ticket is still
make it a bigger thing you make it more
fun let us have our weddings like you
guys want to go do it I've already got
that kind of time I would love for you
to do it pull up yeah so why why would
you have said that yeah pull up bro
he feels a wave coming oh I'm going to
start
I'm in danger